this is going to be a weird question but
when was the first time you ever punched
someone
bro i got in so many fights was that was
that the first time you ever punched
someone
did you not fight with like oh wait do
you only have a sister i only had a
sister
oh dude i have three brothers if i punch
my sister
my my dad would my dad was he used to
say this one threat it's like a legit
threat right where like if i did
anything like bad in public he just like
grabbed my ear and just whispered being
like i brought you into this world i can
easily take you out
my dad won't remember that but i
specific like it's an eight-year-old
that's like
i'm sorry [ __ ] 101 me and my brothers so
we had three brothers right
yeah so it was wrestlemania like oh yeah
we must have fought i must have been in
this fight like three days of the week
right right um was it actually fist
fights or was it like oh yeah it got to
the point where we were like actually
start like full on punching each other
yeah we hated each other i love them now
i love you guys back
then it was like [ __ ] because oh god
there's so many fights but yeah
my dad had this thing we called it like
he's probably gonna kill me if i say
this but he had this thing called the
murder stare
and like you know when you started
[ __ ] up and he would look at you and
you're like
he's like bro you're one step away from
like losing everything
i will end you right now it was the look
where you were he was like don't do it
don't do one more thing
i'll end you i love you dad by the way
because i was an only child so i i had
never had to grow up with any siblings
never had to share anything
um but yeah that was i had a fairly
uneventful childhood because of that i
think in 2020 we call that privilege
i got bullied so much in school so i
just started just [ __ ] punching
everyone back
i guess yeah if you get bullied at
school you probably have like a lot of
people yeah i mean after i started
punching
back and you know actually getting
fights people just left me alone because
they knew if
they would go for someone else who
wouldn't fight back yeah exactly should
i just challenge them to a chess game
i should have man that would have
definitely worked against kids you
should have challenged them to a chess
game and then the moment you when you
just punch them in the face
it's like double down on it double check
me
oh my god dude [ __ ] dude there's so many
[ __ ] times
as kids but i i don't mind it was so bad
i don't know what stories i could tell
if you want any
i mean i'm just trying to think like
when was the i did you ever punch anyone
in school
like full-on punch someone yeah i have
um
what reason uh because this kid it's
always dumb as [ __ ] in the sky
yeah it's because this kid in my high
school was giving me [ __ ] like
he was the bully about you but the thing
is he was that one bully that
you know how some bullies are kind of
like popular with the kids that they
don't bully
yeah this kid because he bullied
everybody like
every single person everybody [ __ ]
hated this game and
of course eventually he made the rounds
and the next target was me for whatever
reason
but and obviously going to a high school
where it's a 99
white boys and i'm the only one with a
non-white bloodline
of course yeah he's going for the low
hanging fruit
yeah yeah yeah so he would you know say
all these like
horribly racial slurs at me and stuff
and uh
and just one day he got he was just
really and i didn't mind the racial
slurs it's it's when he got
up to my face i hate it you know i hate
that so much there's a difference
between a bully
shouting across the playground yeah yeah
i don't mind that stuff yeah which is
fine right because that shit's easy
but respect my personal space yeah right
like the moment you cross
into my personal space that's when the
hands come out yeah
and i i never punched anyone in my life
up until that point yeah and i was like
okay there's only one way that this kid
is going to stop
and he's like and in my head i was like
doing a kaiji episode where i'm like if
i punch him i'm either going to die
or or i'm gonna come out of this
alive joey's like death noting every
action
bad this is like the total opposite the
way i used to think about it i was like
just just punch and figure it out
oh no no no i was always the person who
was like okay what's gonna happen if i
go
down it was like a visual novel right
it's like punch or not punch and it's
like
i don't know i don't want to get the
band i want to get the bad end right
so i was like oh so i was like there's a
very good possibility that if i punch
i'm going to just like
bat him and i was like but this kid was
just
relentlessly just like shouting in my
face and just you know like and then the
moment he started like pushing me around
as well that's when
that's when i think i just snapped yeah
yeah yeah yeah wail back and just
knock this kid in the chat like the
[ __ ] bucky move on
knocked him in the chin and he fell down
on the ground and
he just kind of walked off and then
nobody in my year [ __ ] with me
that's good that yeah it was like okay
oh this all right that was the good end
that was good
you know i'd never recommend like
fighting back because it can normally
like it can go like two ways right
one you can get your kick beat the [ __ ]
up yeah or
everyone else will want to challenge you
everyone's thinking oh you think you're
hot [ __ ] all right
that's like the start of a [ __ ] anime
oh listen all the nerds
i don't think so oh my god dude there
was kids i used like spit on each other
in school and
it was that was the stuff that bothered
me the most like yeah you can call me
[ __ ] don't spit on me what the [ __ ]
yeah i hated high school did you guys
have this i don't know if this is only
an australian high school thing but
the last year of the 12th grade like
literally the day before graduation
i forgot what it was called it was i
think it was called like year utop free
day
where basically the 12th graders for the
last day of high school
they can just run around the school and
do whatever the [ __ ] they want
i think we had something similar in our
school yeah what you guys didn't have
but like our school took that free day
literally where some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
would happen like we
we somehow uh uh we you know the the
it started off quite innocently like
yeah you know putting lube all over the
stair rails and stuff like that and
another one was going into one of the
teachers offices and filling his entire
cup uh
entire floor with cups full of water
so that he couldn't like go into the
into his thing like that
and then it got too far when uh
one of i think was like a group of boys
they got one of the
teachers cars and i don't know how the
[ __ ] they did it
i think i was driving a mini so it was
like relatively small car
and they somehow put the car on top of
one of those school buildings
like on the roof what and i mean that's
too far but that just sounds impressive
honestly the engineering what are the
logistics behind
i wasn't there to witness it but imagine
just walking to school and you're
walking
you know along the school uh like wall
yeah and you just look up and there's
just a car
sitting there i'm just like oh how did
that guess have been in like the news or
some [ __ ] no
no no no this is like this is quite
frequent that sounds like a scene from
some
american what do you mean frequently
that's this sounds like a scene from
some american high school movie that you
watch and you're like oh this is so
[ __ ] stupid this one
happened i don't know i don't know if my
high school still does it but
that's newsworthy in the uk i think
right yeah that would be yeah
of course [ __ ] hell no even the even
the girls schools would go crazy like
that as well just
what the [ __ ] because it was you know it
was the last last day of high school
right yeah like
do whatever the [ __ ] you want while you
can because after this day
you have adult responsibility so it's
like just it's it's it's you know
it's the miley cyrus effect right it's
like just get all that [ __ ] out of the
way
once the contract has ended and you're
good to go right well like i said he
must have learned some good skills from
being able to [ __ ] get a mini on a
school roof
yeah how would you do that even if it
wasn't like a multi-story
building it was like it was like a
demountable so it was just like just
getting it up but still
still there's like eight of them
coordinate this lift
like i had nothing to go wrong i wasn't
i wasn't there to witness it but it was
awesome just
staring across the school grounds and
just seeing a [ __ ] mini
on top of it yeah that was crazy how do
you convince kids to join yeah so we're
to lift the teacher's mini
i need like five boys who's in it's like
all right let's [ __ ] do it yes